hey herzlich willkommen bei uns herzlich
willkommen bei zdf heute live falls ihr
euch gerade fragt wer ist denn jetzt nur
ganz kurz vor mir ich bin christ an ich
bin der neue im team und ich freue mich
sehr auf die diskussion mit euch auf
eure fragen anregungen in der kommenden
zeit gern natürlich auch zu unserem
heutigen thema kennt ihr alles wie
gewohnt könnt ihr uns schicken gerne per
mail adresse wird jetzt auch
eingeblendet für euch zdf heute - live
at
zdf.de oder ihre haut ist einfach direkt
in den chat das ist kein problem ich
habe das im blick ich leite das weiter
wir schauen gemeinsam heute mit euch auf
die situation rund um den russischen
angriffskrieg auf die ukraine da liegt
der fokus aktuell auf der halbinsel krim
und das ist auch der ort den russland
völkerrechtswidrig annektiert und der
krieg damit beginnen das ist auch der
ort an dem wir heute aber vielleicht
auch an der möglichen scheidepunkt
stehen und auch die frage sabotage oder
raketen ihr seht das eingebildet denn
wie schon vor einer woche meldet die
russische seite heute explosionen
spricht von sabotage doch ist das
wirklich der grund oder waren es nicht
doch eben gezielte raketentreffer durch
ein neues waffensystem der ukraine das
ist unsere frage heute die vertiefen wir
mit unserem korrespondenten und auch mit
einem militärexperten vor zeigt uns aber
eine stadt fällt erst einmal was da
heute passiert ist und auch vor einer
woche
wieder explosionen auf der von russland
annektierten ukrainische halbinsel krim
wieder hat es ein munitionslager
getroffen diesmal im norden das teilten
russische behörden mit auch eine
umspannstation für die stromnetz
versorgung in der nähe ist in brand
geraten zwei menschen sollen verletzt
worden sein
das verteidigungsministerium hat
offiziell mitgeteilt dass es sabotage
war niemand darf derzeit in das
betroffene gebiet hinein wenn die
explosionen aufhören wird die
untersuchungskommission ihre arbeit
aufnehmen um die hintergründe zu klären
laut verwaltungschef mussten 3000
einheimische in sicherheit gebracht
werden weil zum teil nicht detonierte
munitionsreste in privaten gärten
gelandet sind und entschärft werden
müssen
die stücke sind bis zu uns in den hof
geflogen
wir haben rauchwolken gesehen aus der
richtung wo das armeelager ist splitter
und holzsplitter sind überall geflogen
dann sind leute gekommen und haben uns
gesagt wir werden euch hier raus bringen
bei den explosionen sind auch
bahnstrecken beschädigt worden diese und
die stromleitungen werden repariert
reisende müssen auf busse ausweichen
offiziell äußert sich kiew zu den
explosionen auf der krim nicht
alles was den russen schadens gefällt
mir natürlich jeder explosion alles was
den nachschub von munition waffen und
soldaten auf feld bringt uns den sieg
näher
bereits vor einer woche hatte es schwere
explosionen auf einem
luftwaffenstützpunkt in sag i im westen
der krim gegeben dabei sei ein mensch
getötet 14 weitere verletzt worden die
russischen streitkräfte führen die
detonationen auch versehentlich
explodierte munition zurück wer wirklich
hinter den attacken steckt kann von
unabhängiger seite nicht überprüft
werden fakt ist aber dass auch die
aktuellen explosionen dem russischen
image als garant für die sicherheit der
krim schaden
also wir haben es gesehen zwei
empfindliche schläge gegen russland
innerhalb einer woche und jetzt eben die
frage was genau steckt dahinter und wie
reagieren beide seiten das vertiefen wir
jetzt mit unserem korrespondenten in der
ukraine vor tanner hebestreit ist das
erst mal schön guten abend herr schön
dass du bei uns bist
ich sag mal nach mainz und dir alles
gute für die premiere heute vielen dank
lieb von dir dass du das ansprichst
hannah wir haben die ersten reaktionen
auch gesehen in dem beitrag gerade von
von anne lass uns das noch einmal
vertiefen du hast heute mit dem sprecher
des militärkommandos in odessa
gesprochen was hat der konkret gesagt
und wie hast du ihn auch dabei erlebt
naja es ist ja manchmal so dass ein
lächeln mehr sagt als viele tausend
worte ihr habt ihr ja eben in eurem
stück drin gehabt am ende dieser
aufnahme hat er breit grinsender
gestanden ich nehme an das hat ein
bisschen damit zu tun vor einer woche
bei dem ersten
ereignisse auf dem flugfeld hatten sich
einige ukrainische offizielle damit
gebrüstet das wäre erfolg einer wie auch
immer gearteten ukrainischen aktionen
darauf hin dass präsident zurück
gegriffen und gesagt leute ihr könnt ihr
nicht hergehen und sagen was wir machen
das offenbar dem feind unsere strategie
und so haben sie halt heute diese diese
geschichten erzählt er sprach davon da
ja dann hat er wieder irgendein russe
seine zigarette da hingeschmissen wo sie
nicht hingehört was
da genau am boden passiert ist ich
glaube er hat eindeutig mehr gewusst als
als er uns gesagt hat und es gibt aber
noch eine weitere nachricht diese aktion
nicht bestätigt russische zeitungen
berufen sich auf augenzeugen wonach es
auf einem weiteren militärflugplatz auf
der krim heute auch explosionen gegeben
hat das ist allerdings alles so nicht
offiziell bestätigt worden wir geben nur
die beobachtungen von augenzeugen wieder
mit dem wir auch nicht selbst gesprochen
haben aber das scheint einiges im gange
zu sein
danke dir dass du das für uns nochmal so
einordnet und auch hier mit uns teilt
was ist darüber konkret jetzt vielleicht
auch noch ja zu erfahren am abend oder
wird sich das erst in den nächsten
stunden oder auch tagen herausstellen
was glaubst du da
ja das ist natürlich eine millionen
dollar frage ich glaube nicht dass sich
irgendjemand im ukrainischen behörden
offizielle hinstellt und sagt wir waren
das und haben es so und so gemacht es
gibt zeitungsbericht die new york times
zum beispiel hat er etwas geschrieben
dass die ukraine truppen oder
spezialeinheiten auf dem boden der krim
im einsatz haben sollen danach haben wir
diese sprecher des oberkommandos zero
dass er auch gefragt da wurde einfach
einmal ganz schmallippig und einsilbig
und sagte die quelle hätte die zeitung
nicht angegeben und wenn die zeitung die
quelle nicht an gäbe würde er dazu
überhaupt nichts sagen
ja da muss man jetzt gucken sind das
irgendwie neu entwickelte ukrainische
waffen die dahin geschickt worden sind
oder sind das leute die am boden dort
zugange waren ich weiß ihr habt ja im
laufe der sendung noch militärexperten
die da vielleicht mit deren wissen und
hintergrundwissen licht in das dunkel
bringen können absolute sprichst es an
da sprechen wir gleich darüber mit
gustav dressel er wird uns das einordnen
twitter auch nochmal hintergründe
liefern können ganz kurz vielleicht noch
mal bei dir du hast es schon
thematisiert
du hast zwischen den zeilen versucht er
heute was bei ihm beim ober kommandanten
rauszubekommen vielleicht nimmst du das
noch mal mit was war noch
gesprächsthemen in dem gespräch heute
zwischen euch und was man da vielleicht
erkenntnisse
es ging um die sicherheitslage hier
rundum odessa er sagte so ein bisschen
natürlich besteht immer noch die gefahr
einer russischen landungsoperation
deswegen sind filmaufnahmen am hafen
immer noch strikte verbote davon also
nicht mal irgendwie vorbei gehen und die
falsche richtung ein foto machen da
haben die sehr große sorge vor er sagte
aber zugleich auch dass die russischen
einheiten im moment nicht die power
hätten das zu machen empfehle die
luftunterstützung und auch am boden
hätten sie nicht genug leute das zu
machen allerdings seien sie sehr aktiv
in der luftaufklärung mithilfe von
drohnen dann würden sie gucken wo die
ukraine ihre luftabwehr positioniert hat
wo er am strand leute sitzen und
aufpassen stichwort strand es gab am
wochenende ich weiß nicht ob wir das
mitbekommen habe
striktes badeverbot am stand von odessa
weil die gegen halt vermint ist und
immer wieder erreichen sich da offenbar
diese minen los und es gab am wochen
eine explosion ganz in der nähe vom
strand die auch drei menschen die da
illegalerweise gewartet haben das leben
gekostet hat
sagte uns hannah hebestreit zdf
korrespondent vor ort in der ukraine
vielen dank für deine einschätzungen und
auch für die neuigkeit dass es womöglich
nicht nur die explosionen heute morgen
gegeben haben soll sondern auch noch
weitere dass da bleibst du natürlich
dran um das genau zu verifizieren ob das
stimmt und auch wir und ihr werdet es
dann sicherlich auch auf unseren kanälen
erfahren auf zeit erfreute in der app
natürlich auch im tv vielen dank
bleiben wir dann aber bei den
bestätigten informationen und die sind
natürlich von heute morgen eben die
detonation eines munitionslagers die
russische seite spricht er heute auch
danach von sabotage es ist ein
überraschendes eingeständnis von dem
start der jahrzehnte durch einen
riesigen propaganda apparat das bild
aufgebaut hat von einer
unverletzlichkeit von einer
unantastbarkeit
und auch jetzt im krieg zieht sich das
eigentlich die ganze zeit durch putins
propaganda apparat keine schwäche
eingestehen fakten leugnen für den
eigenen zweck umdrehen woher kommt jetzt
also dieses eingeständnis es ist
vielleicht ein zeichen wie hat russland
diese schläge wirklich treffen oder ist
es doch nur auch ein weiterer teil der
propaganda strategie diesen fragen
wollen wenn sie jetzt auch weiter nähern
und der ursprung der liegt womöglich im
widerstand aus der eigenen bevölkerung
gegen den krieg nina niebergall nimmt
uns da mal mit
normalerweise melden sich hier
wehrdienstleistende und rekruten zu
dienst eine militäreinrichtung in
nischni über tops keine großstadt mitten
in russland genau das will dieser
brandstifter offenbar verhindern das
video wird bei youtube geteilt
mutwillige zerstörung oder eine form des
protests
die aktion ist laut einer recherche
russischer journalist innen kein
einzelfall das investigativ magazin die
insider zählt 23 attacken auf
einberufung center meist brandanschläge
mit selbst gebastelten molotow-cocktails
wir konnten die echtheit der videos
verifizieren es könnte sogar noch mehr
solcher anschläge gegeben haben denn
seit kriegsbeginn gibt es immer wieder
meldungen über mysteriöse brände wie
hier in einem chemiewerk nahe moskau die
hintergründe unklar
hier begann die brandserie ein
forschungsinstitut der luft und
raumfahrt verteidigungskräfte brennt
entweder ein ort 180 kilometer von
moskau entfernt manche der feuer sind in
grenznähe und damit in reichweite
ukrainischer waffen es könnte sich
theoretisch ukrainische angriff
verhandeln manche aber sind viel zu weit
weg
und dann entgleisen seit kriegsbeginn
auffällig viele züge in russland laut
die insider 63 zwischen märz und juni
fast anderthalb mal so viele wie im
vergangenen jahr die russischen behörden
sagen technische fehler das investigativ
magazin sagt sabotage im netz rufen
aktivisten dazu auf gleise zu
manipulieren die fotos landen etwa auf
dem telegramm kanal mit dem titel stoppt
die waggons das ziel die panzer die in
die ukraine transportiert werden
aufzuhalten militanter protest in einem
land in dem es eigentlich gar keinen
protest mehr geben darf
und doch ist er da der widerstand gegen
den russischen angriffskrieg auch aus
der eigenen bevölkerung wir gucken auf
die explosionen heute und schauen auf
unsere frage sabotage oder doch
raketenangriff und da begrüße ich jetzt
bei uns gustav gräßel er ist
militärexperte hat er insbesondere auch
die strategie russlands im blick er ist
ehemaliger österreichischer offizier und
jetzt am european council on foreign
relations in berlin schönen guten abend
adresse vielen dank für ihre zeit guten
morgen herr
dressel nehmen sie uns vielleicht zu
beginn mit in ihre erkenntnisse in ihre
informationen was ist das
wahrscheinlichste szenario von den
einschlägen die da heute morgen passiert
sind
wir liegen jetzt auch keine anderen
quellen froh dass wir vorher gesehen
haben bilder aus dem internet
wir sehen auf diesen bildern relativ
wenig denn die die explodierenden
gegenstände befinden sich dahinter wir
sehen aber jetzt zb im unterschied zu
den bildern die letzte woche vom
luftwaffenstützpunkt sagt gekommen dass
es hier um oberirdisch explosionen geht
also gerade bei dem video das jetzt
eingeblendet zehn
jahren sind brände da war die explosion
schon vorher da sieht man so eine eine
sphärische druckwelle
dh das was auch immer da explodiert ist
das hatte ihn sozusagen den weg nach
oben hatte der druck kein nennenswertes
hindernis mehr und das deckt sich mit
informationen
dass auf einem bahnhof in st auf der
krim munition gelagert werde sehr
unordentlich wenn man das so sagen darf
einfach neben der eisenbahnstrecke dass
das lager
wo er vor allen dingen artillerie und
munition gelagert wurde
schwach bewacht wurde das heißt für
diesen angriff ist die hypothese dass es
sich um einen angriff von partisanen
oder spezialkräften
gehandelt hat nicht nicht auszuschließen
denn wie gesagt einen
bahnhof zu wien werden auch deutschland
auskennen dann sozusagen kurzfristig zum
munitionslager gemacht wird der ist
natürlich viel leichter anzugreifen wie
eine etablierte luftwaffenbasis wo es
anzeigen gibt wo sicherungen gibt
wo russland über jahre hin in die
sicherungsmaßnahmen schon investiert hat
da kann ich auch bei oberirdisch
gelagerte munition also munition die in
den holzkisten am
bahnsteig liegt kann ich natürlich auch
viel leichter diese angreifen mit allen
möglichen hand tragbaren waffen die
brandgeschosse etwa verschießen können
während bei der luftwaffenbasis wo die
munitionsbunker untätig sind muss ich
dann wirklich mit
mit sehr massiven geräte anfahren da bin
ich da hinein kommen damit ich an die
unterirdischen
munitionslager rankommen diese zur
detonation
bringen kann also in dem sie heute
es ist eine unwahrscheinliche hypothese
das ist ein sabotageakt war dafür
spricht auch zb dass russland die
russische streitkräfte jetzt die gegend
abgeriegelt haben leute evakuieren und
checkpoints einrichten und die leute zu
kontrollieren die rein und rausgehen aus
diesem gebiet das war etwa vor einer
woche bei dem angriff auf sacchi nicht
der fall wir gehen gleich noch mal
konkret auf die unterschiede zwischen
dem angriff vor einer woche und jetzt
heute ein danke erst mal für ihre
einordnung für für den für die attacke
heute ich leite ihn direkt mal eine user
frage weiter die bei youtube reinkommen
die kommt von rade vortex und er fragt
was wenn sich dann auch ein angriff von
ukrainischer seite bestätigt also wenn
da jetzt sozusagen die bestätigt kommt
wir waren das auf die art und weise wie
sie es vielleicht doch beschreiben wie
würde russland dann reagieren
nicht anders als bei den vergangenen
angriffen reagiert hat also es gab es
schonmal ukrainischen angriff aller
relativ am anfang des krieges auf einem
luftwaffenstützpunkt in der nähe von
billiger dort ist gab angriffe auf lager
ist gab angriffe auf
eisenbahnbrücken
in russland selber wo man relativ gut
weiß oder wird unter der hand weiß dass
das natürlich die ukrainer waren musiker
aufnahmen gibt von vom ukrainischen
drohnen wie sie dieses das ziel
anfliegen und sich dann ist auch die
öllager stürzen und das kommt natürlich
in russischen staatsmedien dann einfach
nicht vor
russland führt diesen krieg so wie es
ihnen führen kann im rahmen dessen was
man innenpolitisch als verkraftbar
hinnimmt dass und daran ändert auch ein
angriff der ukraine auf die krim selber
nichts ist natürlich peinlich für
russland gerade sollte der angriff
letzter woche eben durch ukrainische
ballistische raketen vorgenommen worden
seien weil man sich ja damit brüstet
flieger abwehrsysteme zu haben die diese
ahnung für sich abschließen können und
zwischen können und tun ist natürlich
auch immer ein unterschied und aus der
dass dieses delta so groß ist das ist
natürlich jetzt unangenehm dass
abspricht mann darüber dazu passt dann
auch direkt folgende user frage von
norbert kranz die kommt auch bei youtube
ein warum versagt denn offenbar die
russische luftabwehr da so eklatant
vergangene woche haben sie es auch bei
uns im zdf heute journal schon erklärt
dass auch luft attrappen aufgeblasen
werden jetzt eben diese ja diese dieser
diese sabotage womöglich durch die
ukraine warum versagt ist da und er
stelle aber
da kommen viele dinge zusammen also das
erste ist die ukraine haben schon vor
wochen begonnen viele systeme der russen
gezielt anzugreifen und süden und das
ist auch eine eine entdeckung von vor
eineinhalb woche dass sie dafür von den
amerikanern eigene raketen bekommen
haben aber von denen man eigentlich
gedacht hat dass die ukrainische
flugzeuge die gar nicht abfahren können
aber irgendwie dürfte man da technisch
so improvisiert haben dass es doch geht
die sogenannte ag im 88 km highspeed
anti-arabischen miss all das ist eine
rakete die
radarstrahlen oder elektromagnetische
wellen
auffangen kann und die ziele die diese
ausstrahlen angreifen kann und da gibt
es dann verschiedene möglichkeiten sich
dagegen zu schützen aus sicht jetzt der
russischen liga bären eines ist dass man
die radargeräte abwechslung betreibt
dann immer nur kurz betreibt dann die
stellung wechsel so rausgeht das
bedeutet aber gleichzeitig wenn man wenn
man im modus geht das dann natürlich von
den verschiedenen verfügbaren geräten
immer nur eins oder eins oder zwei
eingeschaltet sind und jetzt muss man
sich vor augen führen wie dann der
rhader operateur in diesem gerät
sitzt dass der bei russischen
fliegerabwehrsystemen im vergleich zum
beispiel zu westlichen systemen wehrt er
ab etwa
dass da ganz andere anforderungen an
einem beginner gestellt werden die
russischen systeme haben einen sehr
geringen automatisierungsgrad und sie
sind zum teil sehr schwer zu lesen weil
sie die den output analog darstellen
selbst bei relativ modernen geräten und
es fiel am bediener liegt das radarbild
zu interpretieren und an seinem
fingerspitzengefühl was da jetzt
passiert und das ist problem wenn ich
jetzt 100 über 160 tage im krieg bin
dann sind die leute irgendwann nicht
mehr so aufmerksam vor allen dingen im
auf der krim nicht weil die ja
eigentlich die fünf monate davor nicht
angegriffen wurde beziehungsweise sich
da wenig bis gar nichts getan hat und
dann steht es jetzt natürlich in diesem
kader kästchen statt auf seinem
bildschirm und irgendwann wird man
weniger aufmerksam jetzt kommt eine
ballistische rakete daher die eine
flugzeit insgesamt von wenigen minuten
hat und wenn man dann in der halben
minute wo sie einem am radarschirm
vorkommt nicht aufgepasst hat dann ist
das unheil schon angerichtet das klingt
jetzt unheimlich amateurhaft das ist
aber in der routine des krieges wie
gesagt wenn man über 160 tage komplette
langeweile hat auch etwas das nicht
unüblich ist und das passiert auch
andere namen auf relativ ähnliche art
und weise
jetzt waren sie sich in der vergangenen
woche und auch andere militär experten
einig dass der angriff von vor einer
woche wohl realistischer weise einen
raketenanschlag gewesen sein soll mit
einem offenbar neuen waffensystem das
ist immer wieder die rede von chrome 2
eigentlich ein system womit man nicht
unbedingt gerechnet hat in der aktuellen
zeit das fand zumindest die indizien
eine rakete oder vielleicht nehmen sie
uns da kurz mit was ist das was wäre das
für ein waffensystem wenn sich das
bestätigen würde
das wäre eine kurzstreckenrakete die
schau die in etwa so aus wie es kann
doch die dürfte auch von den
leistungsparametern also von der
reichweite von gefechtskopf her in etwa
mit der russischen iskander vergleichbar
sein also eine reichweite von maximal
500 kilometer aufweisen und einen
gefechtskopf von etwa 400 kilo ins ziel
transportieren
und damit hätte sie natürlich auch die
die geschwindigkeit und die schwere des
gefechts kopf etwa einem bunker zu
knacken das heißt
wenn auf einer luftwaffen stützpunkt
liegt er die munition nicht einfach so
offen irgendwo rum auf einem
luftwaffenstützpunkt muss man damit
rechnen dass dann nicht nur der
angegriffen wird sondern dass eben auch
unfälle passieren dass beschädigte
flugzeuge versuchen zu landen etc
deshalb ist ja dort auch der baulichen
schutz für munition und treibstoff
bunkern hör und diese rakete hätte die
die kinetische energie auch schwere
bedrohung decken zu durchschlagen auch
tief in ihr reich einzudringen und dann
unterirdisch eine detonation
hervorzurufen die ist kann da wenn es
eines kann der angriff gewesen wäre dann
würde dies kann damit über
2600 meter pro sekunden aus einem sehr
steilen winkel auf dieses ziel
herabstürzen und etwa ein ähnliches
müsste man im falle dieser dieser chrome
oder bremen zwei annehmen und dann legen
wir schon in dem bereich erstmals wurde
angriff natürlich sehr schnell
vonstatten geht und zweitens wo wir wo
wir
betonbunker auch relativ gut knacken
können hat sich was an ihren indizien
von vor einer woche dass die ukraine
möglicherweise im in besitz dieses
systems ist
zur heutigen situation geändert oder ist
das immer noch derselbe stand es ist
immer noch dasselbe stand als auch die
tiefen krater die man auch noch den
satellitenbildern von der
luftwaffenbasis sieht bestätigen
eigentlich diesen eindruck dass es ganz
schwere große unterirdische
detonationen auf dem
luftwaffenstützpunkt gab
die ukraine halten sich natürlich
komplett bedeckt nur diese aktion man
weiß auch nicht wie viele raketen sie
jetzt wirklich haben es ist ein system
das sich in der probe fahren das os
wahrscheinlich einige testraketen gibt
wie viel davon aber fertiggestellt
werden konnten ist natürlich die große
frage und vor allen dingen jetzt aus
sicht der ukraine wenn ich weniger
raketen habe dann versuche ich natürlich
den gegner maximal zu verunsichern indem
ich ihm im unklaren lassen was mit
diesen systemen eigentlich wirklich los
ist und mit vieles davon gibt weil dann
zwinge ich die russen
übergebührlich schutzmaßnahmen zu
ergreifen und wir sehen das zum teil in
belarus wir sehen das auch in
luftwaffenstützpunkten in russland in
grenznähe zur ukraine dass dort die
maßnahmen zum schutz dieser
luftwaffenbasen in der letzten woche
verstärkt wurden dass mehr flieger das
system in stellung gebracht wurden das
sind alles dinge die
natürlich diese systeme aus der ukraine
raushalten und zu einer zersplitterung
die kräfte führen und das ist ja das was
die ukraine erreichen will wir halten
fest die angriffe in der vergangenen
woche realistischerweise raketenangriffe
wir halten fest die angriffe oder die
explosion heute morgen
realistischerweise ausgelöst durch eine
see portal sabotage zwei kniffe aber der
ukrainischen seite offenbar die der
russischen seite möglicherweise schaden
zugefügt haben könnte
die andere gerade schon angesprochen
dass es fast schon amateurhaft wirkt
wenn sich dieses szenario wirklich
bestätigen würde bleiben wir doch dann
vielleicht mal bei dieser kriegs
psychologie was machen denn diese
situation jetzt mit der moral beider
seiten in der bevölkerung oder
vielleicht auch in der truppe
für die ukraine sind diese erfolge
natürlich wichtig die moral aufzurichten
es ist ja die militärische lage der
ukraine noch immer alles andere ist
einfach so umbach not greift die
russische seite an hat mit kleine
gewinne aber immerhin gewinne das heißt
der der vormarsch russlands ist noch
nicht gestoppt auch wenn er unter
schweren verlusten vorangeht er ist
immer noch nicht er ist immer noch nicht
gestoppt und da sind natürlich solche
schläge dann für die für die
durchhaltefähigkeit und für die moral
enorm wichtig auf der anderen seite für
russland ist natürlich ein problem
weil es
ist sozusagen also gerade im
internationalen standing wie man die
s400 zum beispiel vermarkte dass das top
liga abo system überhaupt sind dann
natürlich lege gegen luftwaffenbasen
etwas was hoch peinlich ist und das 2004
schon angesprochen habe es zwingt
natürlich dass man dann
sicherungsmaßnahmen ergreift also gerade
sollte sich bestätigen ist noch nicht
sicher aber sollte sich bestätigen dass
heutige angriff ein akt von
spezialkräften oder partisanen war dann
wehren mussten dann auch gezwungen
eigene munition stützpunkte verteiler
wichtige bahnhöfe auch stärker durch fuß
drucken zu sichern die diese objekte
bewachen diese diese
leute können dann natürlich nicht an die
front geworfen werden wir können weder
in carson kämpfen noch in baumbach und
das ist natürlich dann für die ukraine
auch faktisch militärisch wichtig den
gegner so weit wie möglich zu zerstreuen
damit er keine schwergewichte setzen
kann open eben die angriffs
geschwindigkeit russlands herabzusetzen
und gerade personal die russische armee
hat er ein problem personal aufzutreiben
als er ein problem hat dann aufzutreiben
artillerie aufzutreiben schwere waffen
und munition dafür aufzutreiben dann ist
natürlich gerade das personal das wir
zur bewachung von einrichtungen abgeht
das was mir dann schwer fällt wenn ich
eben ortschaften angreift und diese
einnehmen will weil ich da viel in
vertrieb brauche
legolas fragt uns bei youtube wenn wir
beim kriegsgeschehen weil entwicklung
bei moral sind würde es sie jetzt dann
auch eher sinn machen weiter die
versorgungswege aus russland anzugreifen
anstatt sich jetzt auf die krim zu
fokussieren wie würden sie das
einschätzen mir liegt die krim ist ein
wichtiger versorgungspunkt für den
militärischen nachschub auf der
südlichen frauen das ist wohl der
russischen truppen und sabrina als auch
der
russischen truppen in kaesong hier geht
die eisenbahnverbindungen gehen wird die
die kirsch brücke auf die krim und dann
von der creme weiter in den süden der
ukraine durch den dom was kriege sind ja
die eisenbahnverbindungen zwischen
bonn jetzt zwischen roßdorf und
etwa mario pohl unterbrochen und es gibt
da keine tragfähige eisenbahnverbindung
das heißt der ganze nachschub dem süden
rom das ist auch ein punkt
wahrscheinlich warum dieses
munitionslager so so improvisiert in der
landschaft steht dann eine dieser
eisenbahnbrücken die die krim mit dem
osten also mit der front und afrika
verbindet die ist auch letzte woche
gesprengt worden und damit stehen mehr
russische munitions züge auf der krim
herum und müssen auf der krim umgeladen
werden beziehungsweise umgeleitet werden
und das bietet dann natürlich
spezialkräften oder partisanen oder auch
raketen wer es auch immer war ein
besseres ziel weil hier natürlich dann
die gedichte
explodieren material in so einem bahnhof
enorm ansteigt
da sprechen sie in interessanten aspekt
an denen sich auch unsere user rabl
fragt auch bei youtube sie sagen jetzt
müssen die munitions reserven vielleicht
umgelagert werden das gibt zeit für
weitere mögliche angriffe ist es auch
ein aspekt das fragt er dass die
munitionslager angriffe auch die
munitions reserven dann dezimieren
natürlich tun sie das wenn das
explodiert aber wie stark kann man das
vielleicht schon absehen
man sieht an den zahlen der der angriffe
und das atelier beschlusses in der
ukraine dass hier der russische beschuss
im letzten monat zurückgegangen ist
großteils aufgrund des einsatzes dieser
chinas raketen also eines atelier
verkehrssystems dass die ukraine von den
amerikanern bekommen haben und auch auf
drei werfer glaube ich aus deutschland
diese diese werfern eine reichweite von
etwa 80 kilometern sehr viele lager
entlang davon zerstört und ist es so
dass das die russen temporär aufhält
weil man hat in russland noch wer die
hohe bestände an munition noch mehrere
millionen schuss artilleriemunition die
es in russischen lagern gibt aber das
problem ist die geschwindigkeit des
nachschubs wird herabgesetzt dann wenn
ich viel munition relativ nahe an den an
den artillerieeinheiten lagern kann wenn
ich es wenn ich die bahnhöfe als gute
umschlagen der nutzen kann dann kann ich
pro tag für die munition an einen
geschützten bringen wenn ich mit den
munitionslagern weiter zurückgehen muss
jetzt aufgrund dieser anschläge muss man
vielleicht noch weiter zurückgehen auch
von den bahnhöfen weggehe weil die gute
ziele sind dann verlangsamt das einfach
obwohl ich in großen
munitionsbestandteile langsam das
einfach die geschwindigkeit in der tat
eine gewisse anzahl an munition an ein
geschützt bringt und das gibt den
ukrainern aufgrund des geringeren
artilleriefeuer der geringeren als der
vorbereitung von angriffen natürlich
wieder mehr chancen und mehr
möglichkeiten ihr gelände zu verteidigen
gerade im donbass beziehungsweise gerade
auch im süden
wo sie sonst wenig oder wenig gutes
vertretbares gelände haben und wo
sozusagen die materialschlacht mit
russland und die artillerie schlacht ja
voll im gange ist sehr spannende
einblicke die uns targo safe gräßel hier
für uns bei zdf heute live präsentiert
herr dressel wir sprechen ja heute über
die explosionen auf der team und warum
das natürlich ein wichtiger ort ist das
ist das da der krieg losgegangen ist im
jahr 2014 mit der annexion russlands und
auch heute ist es einen scheideweg und
wir hören mal rein was präsident
selensky zu der bedeutung der krim
gesagt hat
dieser russische krieg gegen die ukraine
und gegen das ganze freie europa begann
mit der krim und muss mit ekrem enden
mit ihrer befreiung
da spricht dass präsident lenski an und
daran anschließend herr dressel ist auch
die user frage von kling klong
0815 sehr sehr spannend wie sieht's denn
aktuell allgemein aus taktisch
analytisch hat die ukraine die ja durch
die diese angriffe jetzt auch eine form
von ermöglichen offensive kommt hat sie
eine reelle chance dass übergewicht zu
bekommen in diesem krieg
also die ukraine hat langfristig eine
chance ein übergewicht zu bekommen wenn
zwei dinge ein treffen das erste ist
dass die rekrutierung in russland in
etwa auf dem niveau bleibt wie es jetzt
sie
dann sind die russischen verluste an
personal in diesen schlachten im
dornbusch höher als das was man
rekrutiert hat und die die kräfte werden
langsam schwächer und das zweite ist
dass die waffen lieferungen aus dem
westen sich beschleunigen das meer
geliefert wird und vor allen dingen das
wichtigen komponenten vor allen dingen
gepanzerte transportfahrzeuge und auch
kampfpanzer mehr geliefert wird wenn wir
die zwei faktoren
abhaken können dann ja wenn es sich da
vor allen dingen bei den
waffenlieferungen nicht mehr tut als
jetzt dann wird es eher problematisch
wie gesagt zur zeit hat russland noch
die die initiative
zur zeit hat
russland noch das angriffs moment das
wird schwieriger das mit verlustreich
die ukraine hat mehr soldaten im feld
weit mehr soldaten weil sie general
mobil gemacht hat weil es auch viele
soldaten aus dem training wieder
rauskommen aus großbritannien weil mehr
offiziere ausgebildet werden konnten um
diese einheiten jetzt auch zu führen das
heißt die rein numerische überlegenheit
ist im grunde schon da gefehlt
allerdings noch an schweren waffen
das ist nach wie vor die achillesferse
da gab es letzte woche auch eine große
geberkonferenz in kopenhagen allerdings
ist bis jetzt wenig greifbares da
rausgekommen und das ist so ein bisschen
das wo ich mir schwer tun
seriös zu sagen wie dieser krieg
weitergeht
jenseits sozusagen eine einer
fortschreibung der jetzigen lage weil
aus also es gibt im westen noch genügend
waffen die man der ukraine geben könnte
wenn sich unsere politiker das trauen
würden aber dafür muss man eine
entscheidung fallen entweder in europa
oder vor allen dingen natürlich auch in
washington also noch mal hinten raus
eine ganz klare botschaft von gustav
presse es braucht weitere schwerere
waffenlieferungen hier bei uns bei zdf
heute live die forderung an den westen
mehr ergebnisse vielen dank für ihre
einschätzungen und auch diese forderung
zu beginn dankeschön gustav presse viele
nerze hindern
ich danke euch auch fürs zuschauen und
ich habe das hier so ein bisschen
verfolgt auch für die sehr herzliche
begrüßung das hat mich wirklich sehr
gefreut das hat mir tierisch spaß
gemacht mit euch trotz dieses weiter
setzt vermögenden sehr harten themas wir
hoffen dass wir so einen kleinen
überblick euch heute aber verschaffen
konnten über die aktuelle situation an
der front auch das realistische szenario
aufgedeckt haben dass es womöglich ein
partisanen angriff heute sein konnte auf
der krim vergangene woche
raketenangriffe also zwei dinge die
womöglich der ukrainischen seite
zuzuschreiben sind das haben wir
ausgearbeitet in diesem stream und ich
würde mich sehr freuen wenn ihr beim
nächsten mal auch wieder mit am start
zeit bis dahin macht es gut noch ein
schöner habt